so where's this getting the political
parties joining me now from westminster
are philip blonde uh who is a former
advisor to david cameron and the
director of the think tank res publica
also in central london is kevin craig
the managing director of political
lobbying and media relations uh the
communications company thank you both uh
for joining us uh mr craig if i could uh
start with you
do you think that this is a winner for
ed miliband in terms of getting the
votes he needs to win a general election
it's a winner in helping ed miliband set
the agenda he's uh for a long time been
engaged on a very clear core vote
strategy and he wants us not to be
talking about immigration which 42
percent of people say is their number
one concern but he wants him to be
talking about equality and are you
getting a fair slice of this economy in
this society so for him very effective
today because he managed he called out
lord fink who is now not going to
launch legal action so it's a short-term
win and very effective but this will not
translate yet into changing votes in the
number of key seats where the election
victory lies why not
well because that happens over a
sustained period of time it happens in
the hundreds of thousands of
conversations that are being undertaken
by canvases week in week out this issue
at the moment is a big deal around
westminster people are thinking that ed
miliband's been bold and courageous he
has to be careful the pushback against
him has already started on a for for
example on guido fawkes tonight but
these things don't meet real people for
weeks and it's good for ed miliband it
makes him look decisive and effective
but it's far too early to say it's going
to translate into changing minds in
thorac or other key constituencies
um mr blonde if labour can persuade the
majority that people better off than
them
are effectively rich and also bad people
that could be a really crucial election
winner couldn't it for labor
well it certainly could and at the
moment according to the latest poll um
on this issue 49 of people think that ed
miliband was standing up for
ordinary people in this affair with mr
fink against uh less than half of that
who thought uh he'd be bad for the
economy so i mean i agree i think he's
winning on this but labour's winning on
this issue in all sorts of ways labour
is thought to be better but standing up
for you and your family better for
keeping down the price of everyday items
better for affordable housing where it's
losing ground is as
is that it remains within its core vote
it doesn't speak to the aspirational
classes it doesn't speak to the millions
of people who want to own their business
and what i find inexplicable in this
strategy is i understand why the tories
are following a core vote strategy
because they're threatened by ukip on
their right flank but why oh why is
labour following a corvette strategy um
it's got to move into the middle ground
if it wants to win and it's as if
they've they're in front of an open goal
but with no goalkeeper and they keep
blasting it over uh the the top of the
post
it's it's inexplicable really let's put
that to uh kevin craig there why is mr
miliband going down this route if it is
polarizing and appeals to the core
rather than to the centrist floating
voter
listen i respect phillip very much but
labor and ed miliband to his credit has
had a strategy for a long time which is
it's not 1997. he made a long time ago a
calculated decision that this country
has moved slightly to the left from
where it was before he's also made a
calculation that labor if it gets out
the core vote and if it resonates
in areas of where where that core vote
is key it will succeed and let's not
forget labor is fighting for the left in
scotland where that all those seats have
come into play and ed miliband and the
people around him they know that he's
not strong on some personal presentation
issues they know he's not strong in in
in this sort of more blair-right agenda
but their calculation which they're very
open about is that people want to feel
society is better
and working for the many not the few and
so one can disagree with it um and as
philip says but that's their strategy
and that they're not going to be
deflected it's time to in their view
batten down the hatches and yes i can
tell you there's a lot of concern
amongst some labour business people that
i talk to about the rhetoric but then
the answer back to them from labour hq
is guys there's an election to be won
here some of this rhetoric is stronger
than maybe we'll implement but we need
to get the core vote out people need to
feel there's a point in voting working
class people people at the lower end
they've just given up on politics thank
you for that kevin let's put that to
philip blom there's your answer
well i think it's a very good answer and
i think i think kevin's right but i
think the strategy is flawed um because
you can do both you can keep your call
and move to the center almost all
successful political leaders who command
the sort of majority that you'd need to
command nowadays uh have done that in
the past and it would be quite easy
think of the distinction miliband made
between predator and producer that was
actually very effective but it was never
fully deployed for all of his attacks on
the wrong source big business he hasn't
really talked about the right sort of
business he hasn't talked about what a
successful small business would need he
hasn't really polarized his own
opposition he could get an enormous
amount of support amongst the small
business community if they created the
sort of offer that would appeal to them
because it is true they also feel shut
out so what i'm saying is actually the
corvo strategy is wrong because the core
is actually much larger there is a large
majority of people who feel they are not
winning from the current economic
settlement but labour isn't speaking to
them okay they're going to have to make
sure they don't need to do much more
thank you both very much uh kevin and
philip there
only 85 days until we find out who's
right